now the notebook variation against
deform is a very tricky customer and in
today's lecture I am going to show you
one interesting trap and counter trap in
this line along with my own story
[Music]
The Story Goes as follow
one of my very close friends invite me
to visit his house and when I reached
there he insists me to play The Notebook
variation which he was researching for a
while
okay the opening goes as follow D4 D5 C4
E6
like to see three and now black plays
the move C6 this deadly triangular and
the idea is very nasty that if white
continue with the most popular choice
namely Knight to F3 then black can
actually take on C4 and in some lines
believe it or not he can hold on to this
extra Pawn
not to mention along the line there are
some cool tricks and traps and you are
about to witness myself falling into one
of the deadly trap in this life
here I continue with a four natural
enough moves stopping the move B5
my opponent responded with Bishop to B4
so renewing the threat of B5 and after
the move each
he indeed continued
anyway okay I responded with the Top
Choice from the database namely Bishop
to D2
however I think this is slight
inaccurate Choice from the world and
black can exploit this magnificently
with this nice Moon Queen to B6 which
actually sets up the platform for the
upcoming high profile trial
now the first thing first a captures B5
is a bad move here because after C
captures B5
black and consolidate his extra pawn and
Top Choice from the database B3 doesn't
fit well here as black has very simple
response Bishop takes C3 Bishop takes C3
Pawn to B4 and after Bishop to D2 and
the move C3
look at that Bishop completely gone back
to his original place and after
something like Knight to F6
with the extra Pawn black has some
tremendous space on the queen side and
no wonder black has some youth scores
from this position
so nope a captures B5 is a wrong choice
however I found the very accurate
response namely Knight to E5
and here my idea was that when black
goes for the king side Castle let's say
either Knight to F6 or Knight to E7
I want to play a captures B5 and after C
captures B5 where I can deliver this
nasty punch Queen to F3
which in fact create some huge problems
from the black side
well believe it or not but along the way
I miss that my opponent has done a small
change that is not playing Knight to F6
but Knight to E7 and you are able to see
why this move will make a great impact
in the upcoming track
here to my surprise black Castle on the
king side
and I was more than happy to grab the
rook in the corner but now my opponent
revealed his nasty Trump and that is
Knight to C6
trapping down my sweetie
black has a simple idea namely Bishop B7
and getting the queen something white
has to respond immediately
okay in the game I played 1966 and after
Knight takes C6
engine suggests that the only way to get
out of this mess is to play D5
but even after this black can play the
move Bishop to B7
and we have some forcing continuation
Queen takes effect
King takes Pawn takes C6 and after
Bishop takes C6
if you count the material white has two
rook and a knight against black queen
and two Pawn
but because of the lack of peace
development this is quite equalish and
both the side has their own chances
so this is the best way white can
respond in this line
but as happened humans do not identify
all of this and in the game I played
Knight to E4 which turn out as a big
time disaster
as after Bishop takes D2 Knight takes D2
Bishop to B7
and when I have no choice to take the
Rook on their fate my opponent can
simply recapture and now if you count
the material white has only two Rooks
against queen and a pawn
which is generally okay but not in this
position as word has to still develop
some pieces on the king side and Castle
meanwhile black has some fast activity
going on on the queen side and all
together if you look at the engine
Evolution here it says that it is
completely losing from the world
so this is one of the wonderful trap
exists in the note boom which you can
definitely consider playing in your
tournament practice
well not so surprising I managed to lost
the game from here
and when the game finished my friend
look at me
and said don't you think I should start
a YouTube channel
hahaha
well that was very nasty response on the
face
and as if many of you knows me the story
doesn't end here guys as watch out for
my nasty comeback
which actually happened in the follow-up
weekend
so let's see how I deliver the
counterpunch with a nice counter trap
okay so we set it again and we have the
same opening D4 D5 C4 E6 Knight to C3
and C6
but this time around instead of Knight
to F3 I played Bishop to F4
and my friend already get shot as he
don't know how to react so he gone for
his routine business that is taking on
Seafood
and probably A4 is more accurate Choice
here however I played E3 allowing him to
play the move B5
consolidating his extra Pawn but here I
sets up an amazing counter trap starting
with A4 undermining the black ponchi
well obviously enough if you look at the
database
majority of the games continue with
Bishop to B4 pinning down the Knight and
protecting the B5 Pawn
but this is exactly white one as black
as straight away fallen into whites
counter trial
so before I move on I like you to pause
this video and find out an amazing
sequence which gives white a completely
upper hand
did you find it let's see
First We Take on B5 and after C takes B5
the reason why we haven't played Knight
to F3 because now
we can deliver Queen to F3
and suddenly my dear friend realized
that Queen to B6 doesn't work here
because white can simply take this rook
and now you don't have Knight to C6 as
this bishop is simply a Gondor
so that's why Queen to B6 is right out
of the equation here that means black
has to play the only move to keep
himself in the game and that is Queen to
differ
stopping the attack on The Rook
but exactly here High unleash my home
preparation and that is
Queen to G3
what a wonderful move and after this I
think black is already lost
white has a double thread namely G7 and
on the b89 and unfortunately for black
he cannot defend both of them
so for example if you play Knight to F6
then white can simply click on G7
attacking both the piece
so that is not a good idea and in the
game my opponent choose the move Knight
to E7
but after Bishop takes B8
he simply realized that he has lost the
peace for absolutely nothing
well the game finished very quickly my
friend plays Knight to F5 attacking the
queen I played Queen to F4 and after G5
very simple move Queen to E5 offering
the queen trend which my opponent
declined it with group 2 G8 but then I
was more than happy as after Queen takes
Pawn takes and Bishop to E5
the dust has been cleared out and at the
end it is white who has emerged with a
clear peace advantage
well don't go anywhere because you need
to hear the response from my friend as
after the game finished when I look at
him
before giving me any chance
he rather immediately said
well you know what
I will stick to my chairs rather than
the YouTube
well that was the interesting story and
most importantly the Trap and the
counter trap I have shown in this video
that's it guys I hope you enjoy and
learn this some nice tactical ideas in
the notebook variation
remember there are two choices from the
Y here Knight to F3 goes into some of
the trappy territory from the black side
where if you are a white in this
position then I do recommend you play
Bishop to F4 and as happen to my friend
you can invite a lot of your opponent
into the counter trap territory where
the game can be finished very quickly
thank you for watching this video feel
free to like subscribe and comment and I
will see you in my next episode very
soon
bye and take care